who knew three months ago that the Lev
Parnas the name left Parnas would be
almost a household name to followers of
American politics but here we are on the
first day of Donald Trump's impeachment
trial in the Senate and not only is left
Parnas in the news daily the White House
is desperate to prevent left Parnas from
testifying at Donald Trump's impeachment
trial so let me catch you up quickly if
you're one of the privileged few that
does not know who left Parnassus I envy
you Donald Trump hired Rudy Rudy
Giuliani as his personal lawyer Rudy in
getting ambassador Murray Ivanovitch out
of the way those are Rudy's words not
mine
hired two henchmen Lev Parnas and Igor
Froman Lev Parnas has chosen to
cooperate and after being indicted and
has the goods on Trump and everybody
around him including we've now learned
that Lev Parnas coordinated physical
surveillance for Rudy Giuliani of
ambassador Murray Ivanovich in Ukraine
which is utterly and completely insane
Democrats want left Parnas to testify
makes sense
I already said yesterday Parnas is
accused of multiple crimes he's not a
clean guy the left should not put too
many of our eggs in the left parties
basket but he does seem to have the
goods on Trump he does seem to have
evidence that would be damaging to Trump
in a Senate impeachment trial so the
Trump legal team is scrambling to
prevent left Parnas from spilling the
goods The Wall Street Journal reports
quote White House officials would also
block any attempt to include testimony
from Lev Parnas in the Senate trial the
people said mr. Parnas and associate of
Rudy Giuliani the president's personal
attorney who was working on his behalf
in Ukraine offered new allegations last
week that have inflamed the debate about
whether senators should call witnesses
in the president's trial which opens
Tuesday Mitch McConnell seems more than
willing to play ball and to help other
Republicans also seemingly interested in
preventing left partners from testifying
and of course when you look at the law
there is no real legally defensible
reason to block left Parnas from
testifying he's not a government
employee there's no issue of exam
of privilege Republicans constantly
complain hey we don't have first-hand
information and evidence in this case
Lev Parnas has it he could provide more
of it they should want him to testify by
their own standard of wanting first-hand
information but of course they don't
because they're all wrapped up with love
Parnas and they know that Parnas
testimony would be absolutely
destructive to donald trump yesterday we
showed you how left Parnas knows
everybody around Trump pictures with
Trump pictures with Mike Pence pictures
with Eric Trump Don Jr Ivanka Trump
Jared Kushner Kelly Anne Conway and on
and on and on they simultaneously demand
a type of evidence that left harness can
provide but want to prevent left
partners from testifying and providing
exactly that type of evidence first-hand
evidence which they claim to want love
Parnas is a material witness if there
was ever one and then of course when you
zoom out you get to a realization that
has been underlying this entire thing
the whole time if Trump is innocent why
would you be against people testifying
innocent people want to prove their
innocence left Parnas is Rudy Giuliani's
guy certainly Parnas isn't some plant by
the left to take down Trump right I mean
if Trump hires the best people and Trump
hired Rudy and Rudy hired left Parnas it
must be because deep down Donald Trump
knows that he is guilty of exactly what
he's been accused of and likely much
more which left partners can testify to
Trump and his lawyers don't want
evidence at trial period that's all that
this is any evidence they can block they
want to block so what happens with left
Partners I don't know we'll find out
soon it's not just left the White House
is also considering classifying the
testimony of former national security
adviser john bolton to try to conceal it
we will also be covering that in more
detail as the story develops probably
later this week today by the way just as
a heads-up we'll be live-streaming
today's first day of the Senate
impeachment trial I want to warn people
we are very unlikely to get to any of
the real trial
my guess is either until like Saturday
they're doing Saturday sessions or even
next week because the first several days
are going to be a combination of
guidelines setting up the plan for the
trial and attempts at obstruction and
dismissal of the entire trial by
Republicans so we're going to start
coverage today if you're going to be
watching today just a warning it's gonna
be a lot of grandstanding today and it
could be a while until the real trial as
we believe it
witnesses evidence testimony etc it's
going to be a while until that starts
but we will be covering it we will also
have a poll question about the trial on
our Instagram page follow us on
instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram at david pakman a
lot of kooky hate mail that I've been
getting it's been ramping up I've been
posting to my Instagram page at David
Pakman quick break right back after this